[Musique]
non
oh
c'était un plaisir de négocier avec vous
sony
changement de programme
à 30 ans
[Musique]
récupérez le laboratoire que n'importe
comment
rang
on voit qu'ils ont pas pris l'option
châssis ils ont plein
alors ça fait combien de temps que tu
est redevenu entre man pas longtemps
c'est arrivé sans prévenir
j'aimerais pouvoir me battre contre les
méchants comme toi tu fais
oui sauf qu'avec moi sa fille nina près
comment à chaque fois
peut-être qu'il faudrait quelqu'un pour
t'aider salue un coéquipier
fr pim j'ai appris ce qui vous était
arrivé vous avez ouvert le portail
quantique et là il ya cette espèce de
singe et de fantômes flippant qui
traverse les murs qui a déboulé et qui
vous appliquez votre matos
et elle veut s'en servir pour dominer le
monde je sais pas quoi
si c'est pas tant que ça qui aurait
imaginé qu'un jour vous feriez apple n
est sûrement pas moi parce que le
cambriolage chez vous c'était nous si on
veut avoir une chance
on aura besoin de vous deux
en main dès la guerre ça c'est l'équipe
chez moi
[Musique]
elle semble plutôt efficace
jean
[Musique]
j'attaque par le au toit par le bas gdl
pourquoi celle en bas
poliment paribas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que j'ai loupé on était tous
ritchie
[Musique]
hank et moi étions associés sur un
projet intitulé goliath votre imac si
c'était quoi mon record je suis monté à
6 mai au 19 m 19 m ça y est vous avez
fini de vous comparer la taille 19
[Musique]